Everything is getting more expensive.
Between inflation, supply chain issues
and the labor shortage, small business
owners are struggling.
So I'm here at the Texas State Fair in
Dallas to find out how one of its newest
vendors is handling rising costs.
We’re going to finish the last 2 orders for the customer.
So we have carnitas,
barbacoa, carne asada, and chicken al pastor.
Add some melted asadero cheese and shredded barbacoa, onions,
cilantro
and the barbacoa. Oh my God. I want to start by just going through
these receipts that you brought.
Tell me what we're looking at here.
The first one that I’m going to
show you is the tortillas.
To have a taco place you need to have tortillas.
Yes of course. Otherwise there would be no menu. So I see that you've got $64 dollars
total for yellow corn tortillas, which is 8 packages.
It went up like 0 a box.
So you're talking about 10% of what we used to pay before the pandemic.
So how much did that number used to be?
It used to be $48 dollars a case. $48 now it's $64.
That alone is a big cost increase.
Yeah.
Jesús isn't alone. In 2022 through
November,
food got over 10% more expensive,
with flour costs up by over 24%
and chicken up by 12%.
Supply chain issues, avian flu,
droughts, geopolitical issues.
They all have an impact on the price of
food.
And that leaves restaurant owners like
Jesús making tough choices about how to
pass these costs on to customers.
I've tried to get the best product that
I can according to my prices.
When you pay $5 for a taco, people expect quality.
Is it five dollars for one taco?
I charge $5.75 for a taco, the octopus
and people won't mind because first
the flavor, the
texture and the quality.
So how have you handled the increase in
costs for you?
The traditional tacos, which is a barbacoa or chicken,
they're $2.99. Before the pandemic, they were $2.25.
The tortillas, the cheese, the meat and everything went
up.
Even the produce, you have to increase it.
People know those things and they
become more generous.
They even tip more because they know
that the cost of living for
all my family, my employees,
I call them my family
because we work 14 hours a day together.
So they have to pay their bills.
So people that are very generous,
especially here in Texas.
How did you determine what your price
ceiling was going to be for your tacos?
What you do in order to produce money and you don't overcharge
is you get the food cost of how much you pay for a taco
and then you do it one and a half times more.
For a lot of people, they don't increase the prices
but they shrink the portions.
But I wouldn't do that.
I won't do that.
I prefer to increase my price a little
bit
than give a small portion.
That's really interesting because right now at
the federal level, the view is that, OK,
companies will start to decrease their
prices if we up interest rates.
But it sounds like you're saying that
once you hit a certain price point,
you're not going to decrease the cost, right?
No, I'm doing the same numbers that I used to do
back before I opened,
but now everything costs a little more.
Jesús learned the tricks
of the trade at home with his father.
I grew up on this business since I was
seven years old.
My father used to have restaurants in Mexico City,
so I tried to do more small things,
but this is what I love the most.
Food is my passion.
Did you grow up in Mexico City?
I grew up until I was
I was 17,
then I come here to Texas. I lived in New York,
Vegas, San Francisco
but the past 30 years
I lived here.
And your dad was in the restaurant space? Can you tell me more about that?
He was there.
He passed away many years ago.
I'm pretty sure he
would be very proud
to see what I accomplished.
These tears are for happiness.
It sounds like a real family.
Yes. that's what I try to run, a family business.
And I told them, if I can do it then you
guys can do it.
It's not all about me.
It's about everybody.
It's very grateful for me to see
when they first start.
They come in now
they have better cars.
They have better houses.
And I know you've had an increase in
income recently because you're at the
Texas State Fair.
How excited are you about that?
Very exciting and very tiring.
Yeah, business is great down there.
So the fair came to you and asked you?
Yes.
Then invite me this year. There's 7
new vendors at the fair and by far I'm
number one. Next, ladies.
Are you able to tell if you've made a
profit from the work you're putting in at the
State Fair?
Yes.
Yes, I've already known that I made
a very good profit.
From the number that I was thinking,
we increased it like 30$ more.
I sell over 10,000 empanadas in
the past 20 days.
Tons of tacos, tons of margaritas
and micheladas. It's the dream.
It's the American dream.